all right spoilers for everything that
happens through episode six this won't
come out until then first question is
for you Jasmine what is the biggest
difference between your approach to
playing the other in season one versus
season two oh well season one
I feel like most of the time Ty was
following the no-eyed man and so it was
really easy to just kind of
follow him whereas season two sometimes
he's there sometimes he's not
um at least when we shot it I don't know
in the edit maybe they'll take him out
completely so
um my Approach was more like something
was like pulling me or I didn't I was
out of control and yeah I was kind of
being dragged as opposed to following
someone there's one there's one that I
can think of of the no eyed man I forget
which episode it is now but the second
you said it it immediately came back to
me
um live for you I'm dying to ask this
please tell me everything about nailing
the line Ty you ate her face the second
person ask about this so yeah sorry
about that is that that line was not in
episode three originally but when we
were filming episode two Jasmine just
ate her face Jasmine just ate the Jackie
dummy face it was there yeah and so the
writers were like oh great and then
added that line into episode three and
then didn't use the footage of Jasmine
eating the face like for fun that was a
that was a choice that you just made in
the moment
positioned by her head and I thought I'm
not gonna like lean all the way down to
her shoulder it's more convenient now
because I'm curious like what it what
exactly are the mechanics of shooting
something like that like what what is
the body so the body is a mannequin and
the body that we eat things out of is a
mannequin with
um chunks cut out of it the chunks that
I cut out of it are then filled with
stuff that we can eat and we tear that
out mostly Jackfruit
interesting I think all of that type of
stuff is an art and I love talking about
it
so it made it look incredible
so skilled yeah they did such a good job
I have a very specific line for you too
Sophie when you tell
um Lottie good game what did you want to
convey in that moment in terms of how
she feels about what Lottie is doing is
that kind of you know I'm not gonna
follow you moment but I'm gonna let you
and your followers be I think that was
just a really like emotionally mature
um choice to kind of just give up to
some extent and realize that this isn't
worth it this isn't going to get us
anywhere
um I think it's a sweet moment and kind
of ties back to the lightness pre-crash
and the how they would have communicated
after a soccer game or blah blah blah
yeah that's the teammates yeah it's not
tragic yeah that was really impactful
and so is the nod they give each other
before walking off into the Wilderness I
love that I'll end with this one for all
three of you so we could talk about it
freely through episode six I think I'm
borrowing this from our scream
conversation but I love talking about
the value of a good scene partner so can
you each name a Time on season two of
Yellowjackets where a scene partner
helped you access something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to reach without them oh my God all
the time oh that happens yeah
happens a lot for me with Sophia Elise
there's something once she has the
contacts in and she is Shauna like
between takes absolutely not but when
we're rolling and she's in it we're all
just in it on action I don't know
something always happens to me I look
into her eyes as Ty and it just brings
out all of this emotion and all of these
impulses that like I would never
consider if I was just writing things on
the page like it only happens when we're
filming I'll borrow your words some
something I read somewhere every
nomination I think so I really do think
so if you I think she manifests things
like she deserves it she absolutely does
I know she's not gonna like us saying
that but truly like yeah she thinks that
are true and that should happen I agree
it really should happen yeah I I feel
like like this group gets the best out
of each other constantly and like and I
just it's a delight to work in this
group of people yeah yeah